mais d'abord on revient sur ces émeutes
qui ont éclaté la nuit dernière dans les
quartiers nord de blois des
affrontements liés un violent accident
de la route suite à un refus de contrôle
de police et bilan de la nuit un
supermarché pillé des voitures
incendiées des pompiers des policiers
pris pour cible le point avec paul boyer
et audrey champigny zone nord de blois
ce matin les habitants découvrent les
stigmates d'une nuit de violences
abribus véhicules brûlés supermarché
saccagés encore sous le choc
on a vraiment peur avec nos enfants même
si on est un couvre-feu et ça va encore
fumer ce que je sais avec les petits du
quartier
ça va encore fumer ils ont disons pas
ils vont pas arrêter je suis tétanisé
moi je le vis au quotidien je le vois
pas ma fenêtre et je le je le vois je le
vis au quotidien pour assurer ses
concitoyens le maire s'est rendu ce
matin sur le marché
il lance un appel au calme j'en appelle
évidemment à la sérénité les forces de
police l'état est mobilisé nous le
sommes aussi
et donc voilà disponible à l'écouté mais
aussi dans la tente de la responsabilité
de chacune et de chacun
à l'origine de cet enchaînement de
violences un accident provoqué en fin
d'après midi ce mardi par une voiture
prise en chasse par la bac après un
refus d'obtempérer
bilan deux blessés graves dont un mineur
le conducteur prend la fuite
dans le quartier les esprits
s'échauffent les policiers les secours
sont prises à partie caillassés
vers 23 heures c'est même un camion volé
qui font sur les forces de l'ordre ils
font feu à 12 reprises
trois enquêtes ont été diligentées par
le parquet pour flagrance violences
urbaines et tentative d'homicide sur des
policiers et trois enquêtes sont menées
de front par deux services différents
et j'espère que rapidement on va on va
comprendre ce qui s'est exactement passé
pouvoir interpeller ceux qui sont
impliqués pour établir des
responsabilités pénales
retour au calme vers deux heures du
matin après le déploiement d'un
dispositif hors norme maintenu sur place
aujourd'hui
l'idée
de façon très claire et pour que les
choses soient soit sans ambiguïté c'est
que nous n'ayons pas de violences
urbaines ce soir et que le déploiement
d'efforts soient suffisamment important
pour empêcher les gens de contrevenir
notamment de contrevenir au couvre-feu
déjà en 2014 la zone nord de blois avait
été le théâtre d'émeutes sur fond de
rodéos sauvages et de confrontation
entre policiers et jeunes de quartiers